un Bélanger bonsoir bonsoir Monsieur roi
je vais vous montrer parce que ça nous a
fait penser quand on lisait ce matin sur
le sujet un film que les Québécois
connaissent bien les invasions barbares
le personnage de Rémi Girard qui va
mourir accompagné entouré de ses amis au
bord du lac il voulait mourir là on
écoute un petit extrait quelques
secondes et on revient
j'ai beaucoup de plaisir à vivre cette
modeste vie en votre compagnie mes chers
amis
et ce sont vos sourires que j'emportais
avec moi
alors dans ce film de Denis Arquin qui
qu'on ne peut pas chasser de notre
mémoire c'est des images fortes Rémy
Girard qui meurt entre guillemets
heureux est-ce que Sonia Bélanger ça
illustre bien une des possibilités qu'on
veut ouvrir au Québec oui ben
effectivement monsieur roi puis je me
souviens très bien de ce film puis en
revoyant l'extrait c'est très touchant
et je veux d'abord commencer par
mentionner que j'ai vraiment apprécié le
travail et la responsabilité que j'ai eu
de conduire ce projet de loi on a fait
un travail très minutieux avec beaucoup
de rigueur et on a eu des discussions de
fonds des discussions éthiques on s'est
fait accompagner par un comité d'experts
on a rencontré plus d'une quarantaine de
groupes nous avons fait un forum et
aujourd'hui ce que je dépose c'est
vraiment un projet de loi qui répond
aux besoins de notre société
vos informations qu'on est connecté à
aller chercher de la part des Québécois
et des Québécoises puis oui ça
correspond effectivement les gens
veulent choisir la date de leur décès à
nos temps naturellement qu'on remplit
tout les critères naturellement je vais
pas revenir là-dessus mais on comprend
qu'il y a des critères à respecter ça
doit être fait de façon très sérieuse
mais par la suite une fois que la
personne est idéale qu'elle a tous les
critères qu'elle est en fin de vie ou
dans la situation des personnes qui ont
déficience physique grave avec des
incapacités significatives sur un autre
élément que nous avons intégré dans le
projet de loi une fois que tout a été
fait que la personne arrive au bout de
sa vie elle peut demander la médicale à
mourir et dans la loi actuelle il y
avait trois endroits où on pouvait
prodiguer l'aide médicale à mourir
d'abord dans les établissements de santé
dans les maisons de soins palliatifs et
à domicile
est-ce qu'on a vu avec les dernières
années phénomène où il y avait un autre
catégorie qui s'intitulait dans le
rapport que j'ai déposé en décembre
dernier Assemblée nationale autre
endroits alors je vais y revenir tantôt
mais c'est ça qu'on veut faire dans le
projet de loi qu'on a voulu bien baliser
les autres endroits non mais par exemple
donc ça peut être un chalet ça peut être
un ami ça peut être chez la parenté bien
sûr ça peut être dans un salon funéraire
est-ce que vous ouvrez la porte à ça
également il y en a là qui sont moins
sûrs ça peut devenir un commerce entre
guillemets alors où on je ne pourrais
pas aller au Mont Royal dans un endroit
public par exemple mais en fait nous
avons dans la loi déposer un amendement
pour dire que ce qui est le plus
important c'est la volonté de la
personne c'est aussi en fait de choisir
un endroit qui respecte les règles les
réglementations en vigueur donc il y a
la volonté oui mais il faut aussi que ça
respecte les autres droits et ce qu'on
est venu intégrer c'est que les 6 et les
cieux sont vu que l'aide médicale à
mourir va
juridiction gouvernementale donc public
qu'on veut que le réseau public puisse
continuer de couper que ce soit pas au
privé pas du tout et on l'a vraiment
balisé dans la loi donc une personne qui
déciderait par exemple d'aller sur le
bord d'un lac d'aller sur sa terre par
exemple j'ai des exemples qui nous ont
été donnés mais cette personne là va
faire la demande va discuter avec son
médecin ou avec son IPS et bien sûr il y
a toute une équipe interdisciplinaire et
ce qu'on vient d'ajouter c'est que la
directrice des soins infirmiers dans le
cas d'une EPS ou le directeur médical le
DSP dans le cas d'un médecin va devoir
approuver préalablement le lieu donc il
va avoir quand même une évaluation
l'hôpital est-ce est-ce que quelqu'un
parce que tous n'ont pas des bords de
lac surtout si beau de que dans le film
d'arcade
qui est-ce qu'on pourra demander d'aller
sur un banc de parc parce que c'est la
personne a passé sa vie au parc du
Mont-Royal ou ailleurs un parc ou
Saguenay en habit est-ce qu'on pourra
aller dans un lieu public où ça vous
dites ça sera balisé on pourra pas faire
ça en fait on n'a pas précisé c'est le
lieu devait être privé ou public on l'a
pas balisé et c'est au moment de
l'évaluation par le directeur médical de
l'établissement ou par la directrice des
soins infirmiers qui va évaluer puis
dans le cas d'un parc par exemple la
première chose qui va être à évaluer
c'est est-ce que c'est possible de le
faire de façon intime dans le cas de ce
qu'une réglementation qui l'interdit
donc ce genre de choses qui va être fait
puis chaque cas va être évalué en
fonction des besoins en fonction des
conditions c'est une ouverture
c'est une souplesse vous savez les gens
veulent déterminer selon leur volonté la
journée l'heure leur médecin la façon
dont ça va se produire mais pourquoi il
pourrait pas déterminer le lieu ok
madame Bélanger par ailleurs il y a des
gens qui attendaient de pouvoir faire
des demandes anticipées on pense à la
filière des maladies d'Alzheimer par
exemple des gens et ça vous dites ça
sera pas avant deux ans que ça pourra se
faire des demandes anticipées pourquoi
mais effectivement puis je sais que
quelques personnes qui sont déçus là
d'ailleurs je vais avoir l'occasion de
m'entretenir avec certaines personnes
qui sont venues en commission
parlementaire et on va essayer de le
faire le plus rapidement possible vous
comprenez que quand on discute des
délais on a mis deux ans pourquoi parce
que il faut s'assurer dans le cas de la
demande anticipée que ce soit bien
harmonisé avec l'ensemble des lois alors
et notamment la loi fédérale alors on a
du travail à faire pour rassurer là que
toutes les conditions soient en place
puis qu'il y a une harmonisation là
entre la loi que j'espère qu'il sera
adopté incessamment dans quelques jours
la loi que j'ai conduit et donc
l'harmonisation avec la loi fédérale
c'est extrêmement important l'autre
chose c'est qu'on ajoute beaucoup
d'éléments dans notre projet de loi et
on va devoir accompagner les équipes
prenons l'exemple des maisons
on peut pas prendre toutes les bouchers
à la fois c'est tellement délicat
exactement puis vous savez il faut faire
les choses correctement on a nous allons
avoir les IPs à former celles qui
désirent faire des interventions et de
l'accompagnement à la médicale amoureux
va falloir les former nous avons les
maisons soins palliatifs à accompagner
nous avons toute le processus en lien
avec les personnes en situation
d'handicap donc les personnes qui ont
une déficience physique grave donc il
faut aussi continuer d'ajuster nos
protocoles nos procédures de soins c'est
beaucoup beaucoup de choses choses à
faire et puis on veut faire les choses
dans l'ordre Sonia Bélanger ministre
délégué la santé aux années du Québec la
climatisé là pendant que je vous ai
rapidement ajouté 40 secondes pourquoi
c'est pourquoi ça évolue si lentement la
situation 2% par année ça a pas de bon
sens oui c'est en fait essentiellement
là c'est en lien avec les conditions de
bâtiment qu'on a plusieurs CHSLD au
Québec qui sont qui ont beaucoup d'âge
si je peux m'exprimer ici et dans le
fond ce sont des bâtiments qui ne
permettent pas l'installation facile de
système de ventilation donc c'est clair
que tous les CHSLD qui ont été
construits dans les 10 15 dernières
années ont les systèmes de ventilation
les maisons des années ça se refait mais
je veux quand même rassurer les
téléspectateurs chaque cieux chaque 6 a
un plan de chaleur accablante et quand
on annonce des canicules comme c'est le
cas actuellement les CHSLD se mobilisent
pour mettre en place différentes
interventions alors les chambres
rafraîchir les usagers augmenter la
surveillance
hydrate hydratée les personnes donc
vraiment tout un processus qui se met en
place ok parce que 2 % d'augmentation
par année ce chiffre-là me paraît
vraiment lent et peu mais on va suivre
le dossier madame Bélanger merci de nous
avoir parlé merci ça fait plaisir bonne
soirée